oh yeah
yeah oh fire fire speaking of firing
welcome back to new rock stars we've
come to the end of season one of House
of the dragon and the rings of power but
before we put out put away our fantasy
after show in the stone casket and toss
into the sea for people to find millions
of years later we've got some lingering
questions and topics we want to discuss
with you you guys this is a big question
presents talking dragons our weekly
fantasy after show I'm Jessica Clemens
look at my hair look at that beautiful
Targaryen hand yeah you guys still know
who I stand for the greens and I'm here
what what I'm gonna eat those babies I'm
here with Brandon Barrick hello Jessica
I can't believe we've already gone
through this whole season two shows two
shows two first Seasons done two
prequels to series or movies that
already exist exciting time so much
fantasy uh packed into this fall season
uh but you know before we go away for
good enough for good until these shows
come back we we wanted to go over some
of our biggest unanswered questions uh
of these shows uh and we're gonna start
with House of the Dragon okay
um so and again we're not gonna give you
any spoilers for what's coming in in
this series based on the book we won't
get into that speak for yourself don't
get don't give any spoilers uh we might
talk about what happens in Game of
Thrones which happens which that Series
has already come out and if you're
watching this you probably watched that
maybe you didn't but uh you should know
these things what if people are starting
with uh with House of the Dragon then go
into game very much they could do that I
guess they're gonna have to wait for
House of the Dragon to be over that is
awesome chicken no uh but we might talk
about stuff that happened in the book up
to this point we won't spoil anything
that's coming on for the show so don't
worry about that okay so Jessica one
thing that lingers in my mind is one of
the biggest changes from the book that
is that we had on this show which was
confirmation that Lenor Valerian the son
of Corliss and rainis uh Mary briefly to
renera uh had kids with rhaenyra except
he didn't have kids with her they tried
uh he tried but in the show they fake
his death so that he can run off with
sir Carl and allow rhaenyra and Damon to
marry now in the books it's pretty much
assumed that he's dead or confirmed that
he's dead there's there's various
stories of how he died and he also the
fight between him and Sir Carl happens
uh like in pentos but wasn't it also
still in the book rumored it was just
like there was like he said she said
yeah there was like a rumor that he
might be alive but like most everyone
agreed that he was dead yeah the book
pretty much made it clear that he was
yeah yeah yeah and it was that that was
that there was just like a question of
how he died who was behind it all those
kind of things uh but now the show has
kind of show that he's alive he survives
he fakes his death he sneaks away uh and
he sails off with sir Carl to go have
fun with the boys I I don't know what
else he's going to be doing but this is
my big question Jessica could we see The
Return of Lenor Valerian in this series
perhaps under a different name like the
book can remain correct and that we
never see lane or Valerian again but
maybe we see they nor lanerian show up
uh and he wants to fight you know what I
mean I would hope he'd come up with a
better name than that but um I do think
maybe we'll see him eventually but just
not in the second season I feel like for
storytelling purposes in the show it
would be fun to see him like if they go
up to like even eight seasons see him
like the sixth or the seventh and then
be like that's the that's the boy yeah
that's the boy and maybe he's like low
down on his luck like straight up like
so bad and it's just like Carl's God
Carl's gun he took my money and he ran
or he got killed or something I lost a
lot of money the child fights uh yeah I
don't know why I keep betting on these
kids I keep betting on these blonde
headed kids the sharpest teeth was the
one I put the most money on no but what
I think the uh I think it was maybe even
more a higher chance of us seeing Carl
than seeing Oh sir Carl coming back that
would and I think that would be fun
they're like where's Layton where
they're like I lost him I hit you
because I'm like what if he comes back
what if he comes back what if he comes
back he goes straight to Damon and he's
like I need more money oh he's like I
need more money
like extorts
I mean stupid idea for Carl to do when
Damon is a Loose Cannon and you don't
want him he knows that you don't want to
bring Damon uh bad news
he kills the messenger Carl could do
that to Damon or I forgot to put on
makeup um he could do that to Damon or
he could go to um well I don't think he
would go to Sir Kristen Cole because sir
Crystal Oh no you're not out of that one
guy yeah yeah I mean I could see him
trying to get revenge for Joffrey on Sir
Chris and Cole I don't know if that
would be successful yeah but that just
kind of like sits with it for a while
maybe him and Carl are on the outs for a
little bit he's like the thing is man I
miss my boo Joffrey I wish he was still
around who's that crazy guy who killed
me yeah oh yeah it would have to be
later I couldn't be secret or it
couldn't be Carl because Carl is known
as the guy that killed him yeah so it
would be like as soon if anyone saw him
they wouldn't ask him for any like
because then why you know in theory
reynis and Corliss probably have like a
bounty out for sir Caro that's out there
no you know if they're still mad about
it they've kind of made peace with the
fact that they think Rainier was behind
their son's death uh they've made
whatever piece they need to make with
that they've aligned with raniera
they're ready to support her I guess
she's the lesser of two evils in their
mind right they get to keep drift Mark
in the family they get to hold on to the
power that they have and as as rainy saw
she sees rhaenyra as the better leader
right renice in this series has this
unique aspect of like being there to see
how both Allison and Rainier act to
viserys's death 100 to see the choices
they make uh going forward and she tells
Cora it's like she's the one holding the
realm together she's the one keeping
these men from plunging it into war real
Time That's the choice the reveal the
reveal of seeing Leonard first off
that's also the thing is I don't think
there's going to be a world in which we
see Leonor in uh coreless and rainey's
are still alive oh they're going to be
memories and they're never gonna see him
again they're going to die knowing that
he's he's still kind of mad at his dad
that's true and it's like in Showtime
it's been like six years but like he's
still mad at his dad in theory but I
think it was I honestly think that
episode where he saw when he was like
sitting in the water and was like my
sister's dead yeah was the turning point
for him him to be like because it's like
he's like yeah there's nothing I don't
care which I honestly didn't know he was
that close to his sister which is bad on
my part but like I didn't have time in
the show to like really get in yeah to
get into his relationship with her but
it clearly affected him to the point of
like I can just run away and never come
back and not care that my parents will
probably think I'm dead well his sister
was very accepting of him that she
understood his situation and she he
probably confided in her a lot they
wrote dragons together they they loved
each other and it's sad yeah he really
doesn't have much to come back for I
would love though as this kind of dance
of the Dragons kicks off greens versus
black to have a few years down the line
lane or show back up again maybe to help
out renira in some way as like hey
thanks for not killing me for real or
thanks for giving me this out you know
because right before he fakes his death
and leaves he's ready to like put it on
the bed he's like I'm gonna be a better
husband I'm going to be here for you I'm
gonna be here for the kids I'm gonna
take care of us and she's like you know
I really appreciate that but I got Damon
I don't really need you yeah for all
that but he was willing to like give it
all up give up what little Freedom he
had he was ready to put it all away to
be there for her so it would be fun to
see him come back and like save her in a
situation at some point uh under a
different name and that's that's how
he's kind of lost to history so I really
hope he does show back up again yeah
maybe not season two but like season
three season four like wouldn't care
unless he's like he has to be like
bad he has not like bad as like a bad
guy but like straight up like I need
something I need help right like I want
to see him that way I don't want someone
to run away on a ship and he's working
on the ship and just be like I was once
a prince like I I need him to be like
I I I don't I don't know why but I think
for storytelling it just makes it better
when it's like he is now alive a risk to
everyone like if anyone sees him I want
him to be the risk right I want it he's
got to keep that head shaved they won't
recognize him as much with that shaved
tank which seems harder during them what
do they use to shave your head uh you
know they all gotten swords what if
they're just burning it off oh no they
got razors
that what is this Sweeney [ __ ] Todd
yeah
she'll make boys
uh that's all I got from sweet time
that's all you need that's all you guys
meat bites uh meat Boys
um I we did there was a comment on our
last video from the user your tube and I
kind of love this idea he said I believe
that as luceris Valerian fell from the
skies surely nor Valerian was sailing
The Siege below and he actually caught
his trueborn son and saved him well the
thing is that's right
that's one of the off-story lines for
and like that people believed there was
like someone that yeah exactly
lucera survived right he survived he
wound up on the like Shoreline and
straight up he was just lost his mouth
yeah and what did he just like get on
bro
I'm not your real dad but I'll take care
of you boy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because we also you mentioned it and I I
watched a tick tock that was going over
the map and was like yeah everything is
very close by yeah they're all very
close right like Storm's end and
driftmark all their King's Landing
they're very close to each other right
there in the steps yeah literally
literally you can throw a rock from
where Damon is to the the iron throne
but like yeah it'd be so stupid for him
to be that close to everybody yeah No
One's Gonna Know Who I Am
uh I wonder too you know it was it's six
years since uh uh Leonor died right and
we know that Corliss left his wife and
went fighting in the stepsons for a
little while and before all that had
kicked off remember when Leonard was
with raniera and he was kind of like man
I just want to be out there fighting in
the stepsons I missed that I wonder if
any point during those six years when
he's hanging out in pintos or braavos or
whatever he's doing in the free cities
he was like oh I hear there's war I hear
the triarchies up to their old
Shenanigans I'm gonna go check because I
hear my dad's fighting and he watches he
could be in a fight on the side and just
like watching his dad what being like
acting like a sell sword and just
fighting off on the side for something
else Corliss doesn't see him please just
checking in on instead and being like Oh
see his dad still got it the old man
still got it
son of a [ __ ] yes and then he walks
away and then he walks away then he sees
him get cut and he's like I got to go
uh yeah later valerian
can we miss you
one of us does he was a good guy I think
he's fine he comes back that's like
being like I don't know I just don't
care if he comes back I know but as like
a surprise from the book I think it's
fun and I love this idea that like the
book has this unreliable narrator or
narrators yeah we don't know what's
actually true and the show is trying to
say this is what's actually happening
yeah this is what history has forgotten
or misunderstood I I guess the reason
I'm like I don't care whether he stays
or goes is more so it's just like again
I want that not justification but I just
want him to be like a risk or liability
for story's sake where it's like him
showing up shakes up a lot of things I
don't want yeah I don't want it to be
like you saw me good and now come with
me I don't no no it's not that yeah you
can't be that and so that's why I'm like
I think it's just best if you just don't
show up him stay dead
I do I I do like your theory though that
sir call shows up wanting more money I
do like that one that that that's a
great idea uh before we get into our
other topics today just one more
reminder to check out new
rockstarsmerch.com where it's your last
chance to grab our latest Obsession
shirt Ashton ruin inspired by the house
of the Dragon this limited edition shirt
is not going to be available for much
longer this is that this is it this is
the end of the line folks so be sure to
grab one before it's wrapped up by the
silent sisters and burn on a funeral
pirate damn damn they can't talk about
it you're silent you know never know
what is it what do they say uh you gotta
kill your baby sometimes kill your
darling kill it Oh I thought babies well
sometimes people throwing babies out
with a bath water kill you Darlings I
think it all gets mixed together uh dead
babies it's House of the Dragon folks so
check out all the great merch options
over at
newrockstarsmerch.com can't wait to
watch a show where less children die
well yeah I think this is the number one
versus like because in Oh The Walking
Dead there's some baby zombies yeah have
is a bit that's some sense but except
but the baby's walking so you don't get
really like sad like this one and a lot
of the dead babies here are not as
because of zombies they're just because
of maesters
look here look here you don't know how
hard it is you don't know how hard it is
to not know magic and then not really
know the anatomy of someone
wash your hands and you just they're
just straight up moving organs around
and they don't know Anatomy yeah and I
don't understand why they I uh they're
trying to learn they're trying to learn
on a on a live princess oh I mean that's
what humans did for a long time here in
our world uh we also want to thank
wendry for sponsoring the show today go
deeper into the canals of numenor and
the minds of Kaza doom and more with the
official Lord of the Rings the rings of
power podcast host Felicia Day and
several special guests provide an inside
look at the groundbreaking series and
what it took to bring Middle Earth to
life each episode of the official
podcast features exclusive interviews
with the series showrunners JD Payne and
Patrick McKay including the very first
full breakdown of the incredible season
finale and what a finale it was Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you dropping
stories in Easter eggs you won't want to
miss watch the rings of power on Prime
video and listen to all eight episodes
of the official Lord of the Rings the
rings of power for free on Amazon music
download the Amazon music app now you
can also listen to music from that show
which that show has had some really
incredible music I very much have
enjoyed it uh so let's House of the
Dragon good good music all around you
never say that about my music uh your
music is okay uh I find it derivative
Jessica oh I'm sorry wow that's the
truth I'm going to treat you I'm gonna
treat you like one of these babies
that's like the singles are great check
out our latest CP available now on
Spotify and and Target and Target she's
at Target uh selling it uh in the
housewares aisles okay I'm standing
there you want to buy my you want to buy
my helmet hey you want to buy another
one all right if anyone offers to sell
you a CD do not buy it don't buy CDs off
the street that's any for anyone walking
around Hollywood I say do it don't do it
you never know what's on it it's not
good all right Jessica my next lingering
question here uh as we say goodbye to a
monarch I want to ask you Jessica was
viserys a good King uh and before we
before we answer that question we got a
little clip from the show yeah welcome
to the show where he was wondering the
same thing before he uh his body
completely fell apart into a billion
pieces yeah but let's take a look at
this clip
will I be remembered as a good King
later what will they say of me I have
not afford to not come good
it hardly makes a good shot
to be sung at feasts in 100 years
500. is it no better to live in peace
than to have songs on after you are dead
there is a part of me which is
she said so yeah he was worried about
that and that was episode I think
episode five or six he had several he
lived for several more years after that
surprisingly he was already in bad shape
yeah both his arms then yeah uh as
Jessica pointed out all right Peter both
of those characters uh and Patty
Constantine the actor who played for
Sarah's what a performance this year so
great so perfect saw him at the house of
dragon Premiere yeah uh a lot shorter
than I thought yeah we saw him at the
premiere screening uh with his family
and if I had known he was the coolest
guy knew now like I would have talked to
him I would have been aligned I'd be
aligned for Matt Smith but we didn't
know I mean because the books they don't
treat viserys very well and Patty
Constantine even said that George RR
Martin texted him and said like you were
a better viserys than my braceris oh
because the book for a lot of these
characters doesn't have the time or the
pages or the patience to flesh out
they're kind of how they're how they
changed over time you know how they had
nuances to them I mean this show is
about characters who are all flawed in
many ways none of these characters are
true good they all have bad parts of
them
they all have bad parts of them
uh so they're bad decisions what leads
to what we consider the darker parts but
was viserys a good King you know he's
talking there like he wanted to be
tested he wanted to go to war but you
know he was a dreamer and not a dragon
writer and he did everything he could to
kind of keep peace in the realm yeah for
good and bad because he was so afraid of
aegon's dream the prophecy The Song of
Ice and Fire that was his concern yeah
um but in the end Otto is quick to call
him visares the peaceful right that is
his song that will live on in the
history books calling him viserys the
peaceful Otto might be the only one
saying it but someone's saying it so do
you think viserys was a good King yeah I
do I thought he was bad at first but
then you also have to think about what
makes someone a good King and there's
too many qualities that are going to be
negative and too many qualities are
gonna be Pro so it's just like yeah he's
the only one that like didn't really
start wars right did keep peace amongst
the Realms and genuinely just was there
because compared to what aegon is about
to do it doesn't seem like yeah he's
gonna be a good King and then what we
see going forward in Game of Thrones
we're like yeah still not really a good
cake so and that's that question of like
if you want to be king doesn't that mean
you shouldn't be king though aegon the
second doesn't want to be king and I
don't think he's he's not gonna be a
good King he's not going to be from what
we're already seeing just that one scene
of seeing him be like I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't wanna and then like
oh all these people love me yeah I want
it literally what have we learned from
all of Game of Thrones like that's
exactly what we shouldn't want so I
think out of the kings that we've seen
through Westeros in time yeah I think
he's been the best one doesn't mean he's
a good one I'm just saying he's the best
one a lot of the king the lineage from
aegon the Conqueror to viserys in the
book you it kind of swings back and
forth between like what you would
consider a good just King who like
follows by the rules and you know might
do some killing here and there but it's
like trying to keep their own peaceful
to like something like Meg or the cruel
right who is awful and will kill
everyone and doesn't care what he has to
do to do that and like rules with fear
and the people the small folk are kind
of like tossed back and forth between
these two variables and then you get
just Jairus who has a long reign of
peace right very long reign of peace and
viseris sees this as his grandkid sees
how he rules and tries to maintain that
because he's given the prophecy as
probably from joharis I don't think it
came from his father because uh I
believe viserys's dad is kind of dead
before he was kind of set up he was
definitely dead before the great count
Council that sets him up as king but I
don't think viserys was really planning
to beat king when he's growing up with
his dad because his dad was not the
firstborn of joharis Joe Harris's first
born son dies at some point and then
viserys's dad thinks he's going to be
king but then he dies too he just gets
like stomach problems but Sarah's
brought that up when he kind of accuses
Otto of maybe killing his dad but right
before he fired him uh but yeah I see
what you're saying though Jessica I
think viserys was a good King for the
realm and that he's maintaining peace
yeah uh you know when everyone wanted to
go fighting the stepstones he was like
no we shouldn't do that it's a bad idea
and it did kind of turn out to be a bad
idea Corliss was and Damon were there
dealing with it for like four years and
couldn't get it done uh and then close
winds up going back there for another
six years it almost dies so he was right
to stay out of that mess but at the same
time he had people kind of pushing him
either way Otto's kind of leading him
wherever Otto wants so you know I don't
know if that makes him a good King he
really only cared about raniera it
doesn't seem like he cared about his
other are kids I don't think you need to
be a good King based off who you love of
your Offspring yes but I mean
you should be setting them up for
success I don't know like I don't know I
it it's like again I guess it would come
down to like what qualities make you a
good or bad kid because it's like yeah
you should be setting them up to like do
that which he was with renera because
renera was supposed to be heir to the
throne so he did he was like I'm gonna
tell you the secrets I'm going to tell
you what to do so he was doing that it's
not his fault that Allison immediately
was like never mind you said this one
yeah I'm gonna throw this guy on here
well you know he wasn't planning on Emma
dying he loved him oh yeah and also it's
just like when you're so busy you're so
busy busy drinking you're busy and
playing with your model you don't
understand your model City in your
bedroom he's King of the center why am I
fighting for viserys
well this was not supposed to go as I
planned but
um yeah I think he's still again based
off of like the prior Kings and going
forward our next king it's like yeah he
wasn't also assaulting random small
folks yeah he was in ruling with a fist
right and he was genuinely like the
small folk were all like even if some
did hate him it was still like you know
we're not gonna do anything though it's
like yeah there weren't there wasn't a
rebellion Brewing underneath yeah
there's nothing oh the only thing he's
like at um thought of is not going to
war so everyone was just killing each
other within the kingdom I guess I guess
yeah I think it could be remembered well
uh I don't think he did a terrible job
maybe not the best King but not
certainly not the worst yeah uh that
Westeros has seen and we'll see uh next
up Jessica
and speaking of this this prophecy the
dreamer of viserys what's next for
aegon's Song of Ice and Fire okay this
was a big surprise uh for book readers
in this show because this is not talked
about in the book and then in the first
episode we get this kind of surprise
revealed that like oh there's aegon Song
of Ice and Fire has been passed down
from King to King to King and it's
written on this dagger the the famous
cats pod uh Valerian steel dagger that
will eventually kill the night King uh
what do you think uh Rainier is going to
do with this information now that she
has it she does not have the dagger the
dagger is still uh uh back at King's
Landing and now aegon the second has it
foreign
that's the reason why I don't have the
attachment to it I'm like uh every time
they bring it up I'm like
yeah but in this last episode in episode
10 we see how Damon is ready to like get
the dragons let's go to Heron Hall with
surroundings and let's burn it all down
but in her mind renira knows I have to
keep the realm together I cannot plunge
the realm into war right now because
what if this prophecy starts tomorrow
yeah in her mind it's gonna happen any
day now yeah because that's what her dad
thought yes uh and he was a dreamer uh
and so she's like this could happen like
so I guess well the thing is I don't
think she's gonna abide by it and that's
what's going to be the fall uh because
if she's like I need to keep the realm
together that's impossible when you
literally just had your son ripped from
you and she's about to go we saw her War
face at the very yeah so it's like she's
like I'll put this prophecy on hold for
a second beep
she's gonna get on her dragon and just
go wild do you think she's gonna tell
Damon about it no and I hope she doesn't
after she got choked I think she's
losing faith yeah I do think they're
gonna start splitting apart she got
choked and she's begging for him during
childbirth and he was just like I'm too
busy ruining at this light up table and
so I think she's gonna genuinely be like
this is the crossroads this is the start
of the crossroads this is where it's
going to start failing I can't trust
Damon with this information yeah
absolutely and there's a reason why he
never knew anything before like I think
that and I think that's what she should
think about is the fact of like your dad
didn't tell other people he only told
you which is how you should treat it
you're gonna probably tell just heires
right and that is it okay I think she
will tell just Harris about it because
in her mind she's like I get you ready
you're the air now yeah you're there
something she said in the last episode
that like you know this the
responsibility of being air is now like
on you like you have got to help me here
uh and I think that will be part of this
kind of bond she forms with him now do
you think her getting mad dagger back is
going to be a main driving force for her
is she concerned about getting that
dagger back
or is she even thinking about that no I
don't think she's thinking about it I
think she's going to be blinded with
like just anger right for a minute and
she'll get the dagger and when she gets
the dagger she'll pick it up and be like
but like right now I think it's more so
about like
the war that's about to happen it would
be interesting to see if you know when
she we don't know how the conversation
went with the Starks in this last
episode I think we're gonna we're gonna
see it I think it's gonna pick up in
season two yeah yeah I think it would be
cool to see if that like you know
raniera if the Starks are like I don't
know we don't really want to support you
if Rainier goes to Craig and Stark and
is like look here's the deal there's
this prophecy a prince that was promised
blah blah blah blah you guys are in the
north you're like the first line of
defense after the wall if this happens
you're you're in the crosshairs so you
need me to stay Queen so that Milan
sticks if Starks want to believe it I
guess if so if she came to me and was
like there's a prophecy I'd be like it's
a prophecy so it might not happen I'm
like this is just an idea there's a
maybe there's a maybe I got a lot of
people to feed right like I'm still
protecting the wall in case other things
happen also I'm a stark I don't really
care about your targaryens and your
dreams
you got your weirdo guides I don't even
know I trust the old guy yeah Tree in my
garden is crying it's great I don't care
about your dagger where's the dagger
yeah can you show me the deck oh there's
writing on it I can't read that okay
okay y'all tricking us again like you
did it all the time this is a trick get
out get out of here don't pet my wolves
don't don't pet my wife don't touch them
with your dragon hands the dragon hands
yeah I think you're right though that
she's not gonna tell David no she says
even Damon was like I don't have time
and honestly these omen's important best
better like ammunition against him of
being like you don't know anything well
yeah I know things we do know that
Damon's main driving force I don't I
still think he does not want to be king
but he wants the targaryens in charge
and he wants to be the hand to whoever
is the king he wants to kind of push
people around but not be like in the
position of having to be king if you
told him this thing though it would kind
of fuel his fire to keep the targaryens
in power but he kind of wants to do that
anyways he doesn't need a reason yeah he
doesn't need like another reason well I
think yeah yeah
yes I'm wondering if
well this will kind of lead into our
next question actually as I say that is
there any hope for Allison and Ramirez
relationship absolutely well as soon as
my son was ripped from his long-lasting
life by your side my brother you're an
Envoy he was there on a peaceful your
third I don't care and no one will know
I guarantee it no one will know it was
an accident I literally am going I'm
gunning for you okay I'm gunning for you
and the thing is uh Rainer is such a
sweet person that she won't go for her
children she's not gonna attack her
children
at this point
I don't think she would I still think
because she's still too much like
viserys in that way where she was like I
need to hold the realm at peace and
honestly you I can't believe your your
son would do something like this
actually I can because your children are
wild as hell Allison her children are
Buckwild and I just lost one yeah I just
lost two within like a week so it's like
you're out of your mind I'm not going to
do the same day yeah well we're assuming
it's the same oh the same yeah those
twice a week just to give her a little a
little time a little time so it's like
no dude your relationship is done I'm
and it's also like fool me one shame on
whatever but like it it's like Otto
keeps doing everything for Allison and
it's like I'm a woman I am the queen and
I am at least standing up for myself
Allison you can't even come before your
dad yeah like you're out of your mind
like I don't trust Allison I wouldn't be
there for Allison she'd lose all my
support I don't care about that damn
book well let's let's have a quick
reminder of where their relationships
are we got a clip here from the first
episode of this season I want to fly
with you and drag them back see the
great wonders across the narrow scene
eat only cake I'm being serious I never
just about cake princess nymeria led her
Rhino across the narrow sea on 10 000
ships to flee their Valyrian pursuers
what are you doing do you remember
they were best friends their BFF and
Allison kept that page look here kept it
it meant so much to her try and rip a
page out of my book and see what happens
we're page out of my book and don't
trust Alex they were gonna fly around
any cake and each kid see the world and
then her son was ripped from his life by
hers well here's here's what I'll say
Jessica and this is not we're gonna
spoil anything here uh the book
in the book Allison and Ranier did not
have this like close relationship or it
wasn't established in the book that they
knew each other when they were kids and
and Allison is presented very coldly in
the book very calculated uh and as a big
foil for rhaenyra and we don't get to
see the kind of softer sides that they
have and at that dinner they have right
before viserys dies you know their
relationship was like kind of getting
repaired and we're near a very
uh appropriately says I'll return on
Dragon back and we know where she comes
back she'll be on a dragon at some point
but I'm wondering if this is something
that the show can do that the book
couldn't do where as the children get
older as aegon and amend and josarius
they get older and they have more agency
over their actions and they're no longer
just doing what their moms say if in the
background we'll we'll discover on the
show that Rainier and Allison are trying
to work to undo this damage no it to fix
it again but you have a good point
I don't care how apologetic Allison is I
understand but it's just like Al runera
has been like every time my sons do
things I tell them to like talk with the
most respect and to do everything not
fight fighting's the last thing yeah but
for some reason
exactly you think you'd be [ __ ] tired
at this point of being like I tell my
children every day to rule with like
respect and sweetness and kindness while
your children are ripping through the
realm killing people raping people like
this is insane yeah so like and I know
that Rainer is a better mother than
Allison and Allison also kind of didn't
really want to be a mom in the first
place
um no they did Rene did not want him
became like she recognized that like she
knew she was like Hey I'm gonna become
Queen one day this is gonna be my
Offspring it's gonna be air I need to
have I need to do this yeah yeah well
Allison was kind of like my dad wanted
this for me right I didn't get to choose
my lover right no um or she'd even get
to choose when she was with her yeah or
with her liver so it was like that's why
I'm just like no I I don't want her to
be and she doesn't have to be there's no
eye for an eye in this I am wondering if
this song of ice and fire I get a thing
that's not in the book if that's
something Rainier could use to try and
talk to Allison and be like look Allison
there's this thing you weren't told
about but it's very important and I'm
wondering if they have that conversation
and uh Rainier utters the words the
prince that was promised and Allison
goes oh that's what he was talking about
either one the crate my crazy old
husband that's still not inside and it's
like oh whoopsie doopsie that's still
not the they don't still have to be
friends for that they don't need to like
she can say like because of this
prophecy the realm and they could still
be like okay yeah I'll make sure to note
that and still I'll write that one down
I'll tell them it's like when are they
gonna be able to talk to her without
Auto next turn or aegon that's on the
throne so it's like I'm not gonna oh
that's why I think if we're near and
Allison can find a way to get away from
the kids and be like let's chat real
fast what is Allison gonna do because
it's like she's not the hand and she's
not the king so she's going to be The
Dowager Queen at this point she usually
yeah she can be like look here please
and what did we learn from Cersei and
Joffrey like Joffrey was like I'm not
listening to you well here's the thing
if Allison goes to aegon it's like I
love you please do this aegon would
probably be like okay Mommy I don't
think so I think now that he has the
love of the small folk he's like I don't
get rid of the windows put some bricks
in it
uh okay Jessica this is this is a big
question I've had all season and all and
all for a while now uh and it's been
brought up it got brought up on Twitter
a little bit so here we go Jessica how
do dragons reproduce
because they did not talk about this in
any of the books no one really knows how
the dragons reproduce okay I I wanna I
wanna see what you think about this
whole system I want to see what you
think we see Damon right he goes into
the dragon mount the volcano uh on
Dragonstone and he he finds a little egg
sack and he cuts open boom eggs like oh
that's cool we've never seen that before
like they make these little gross egg
sacks that look like meteors or whatever
maybe the female dragons like lay the
eggs and the male dragons hover and give
the dragon goo and that's the goo that
we saw that Damon right here gets crusty
on yeah and it gets crusty on the
outside but gooey's still on the inside
oh my God so that's when Damon ripped
through it so that's kind of like a fish
right like salmon yeah they work like
they lay the eggs and then the male
comes in they also follow up through the
current like the moons do you think that
that's what hardens the shell too
because that's how it works for a fish
egg the the sh you know we've all had
row at a sushi restaurant it's a permeal
permeable membrane around a fish egg but
the dragon eggs are very hard right
they're like almost like rocks so they
could get Hearts after it gets
inseminated is what you're saying okay
okay well what we do know from the books
uh there's a lot of debate around it so
you have like septon Barth Grand maester
munchkin and maester thomax they these
three these people they kind of disagree
on like the mating habits of dragons
which makes me think no one has seen
like dragons mate which they could do it
in the caves underground maybe that's
what makes earthquakes it's probably
they could do it in the sky most
vulnerable so they don't want people
they don't want people to know yeah and
if you watch it maybe they'll like bite
your head off they're like mantis or
something I don't know maybe okay well
there there's also the idea that like
they don't the way they don't even know
how to tell the sex of a dragon you
can't tell you can't get that close
right and the only way they can tell is
when it lays eggs so when Cyrax lay some
eggs they're like Cyrax is a female
great to know great to know because I
guess even when they're babies you can't
like sex a dragon you know some some
reptiles they have cloacas which is both
uh
it's both genitalia and like uh an anus
at the same time uh and like with
crocodiles and chickens and stuff like
you have to like kind of check inside
the cloyga to figure out what it is yeah
that's that's all I know so it's hard to
do that with a dragon right I guess when
they're a little baby you maybe could do
it you think that Fury it hasn't
developed you pee and butthole in the
same place that's what a cloaca is you
think the dragons have a people I think
because they're like reptiles I think
they have in your terms of PP and
butthole in the same place okay you put
it in then you feel a different hole and
it's just the butt and you just think
it's a girl then that maybe that's a
girl I don't know but you're not gonna
do that to a full-grown Dragon okay okay
but there's also this idea okay the
dragons have no fixed gender and can be
whatever they need to be all a Jurassic
Park they're like changing Sexes when
they need to uh mushroom tells a story
that uh when jaharis flew uh uh his
Dragon Verma Thor who we saw in the last
episode up to Winterfell it left some
eggs up there uh now that's that's
mushroom who's a little Court Jester and
tells body Tales all the time it's
probably not true uh because those eggs
are unaccounted for or whatever and I
doubt they might have eaten them at
Winterfell I don't know uh can you eat a
dragon egg uh if you could crack it open
I don't see why not okay if you can get
it open uh it seems like a waste of
money but you could do it uh so there
was this I some people believed that uh
a dragon could change its sex when it
needed to but a lot of other maesters
kind of disagreed with that statement
and they don't know so you can't tell
the sex of a dragon we have no idea how
they reproduce I I think they might just
reproduce asexually like when a dragon
needs to make more dragons it just does
it and there's no sperm or egg involved
it just happens I believe any dragon
could do it whenever they want I believe
my dragon goo Theory I I appreciate you
it's gross but I think it's true it's
gross but it does make sense Jessica
thank you because they do talk about
like oh these eggs are from this Dragon
but they never talk about the dad Dragon
it's not like uh racehorses where
they're tracking like thoroughbreds
through generations like they have no
idea who the male is in the situation
they're just like oh Cyrax lights
amazing this is what the internet's
asking and then like if the show was
real they're like there's other things
to focus on I mean they have all these
tapestries of targaryens having sex with
Dragons but no one has caught two
dragons doing it
let's figure it out guys do you think
the targaryens try to have sex with the
dragons I bet yes I bet there's been a
few targaryens who have had very close
relationships with their dragons that
that close that close I thought they
would like share I mean uh you know
Daenerys didn't use a saddle when she
rode her Dragon you think she wrote her
Dragon bear back you think no I'm not
saying Daenerys did I'm just saying that
people have close relationships with
their dragons and if you're lonely one
day okay there it goes you know there it
is also what I just thought about
because of this discussion when Veigar
ate the other Dragon basically do you
think that is the same
um it like coincides with like how you
know like a lion or a Jaguar has gone
crazy because it attacks oh it attacks
like not only its own yeah it's
cannibalistic but it also doesn't really
care to eat it's just like yeah
destroying yeah it just destroys do you
think that's like vegar vegar is just
ultimately like we're like yeah it's the
oldest most like whatever Dragon but
genuinely it's like actually insane yeah
I think that's a good point like it's
it's been captive its whole life uh and
they it's had different writers
throughout the years it's seen a lot of
battle it's seen a lot of craziness and
I think that's a great point it's just
like
I don't care anymore blow fire on my
face I'm gonna kill you yeah I'm just
gonna because like Vega has no reason to
fear Eric's I guess we don't yeah and I
guess we don't I don't at least I don't
I haven't seen it yet that the dragons
uh even if it's not the same family of
dragon it's still like I see that as
another Dragon I'm not gonna harm it but
like vegar we have now seen like harmed
it harmed it harmed it pretty bad let me
tell you it's not coming it's harmed
it's harmed uh real quick Jessica before
we go it's been a couple episodes since
we did this I would like to do a little
talking Talking
Tom Talking Toki wow look at that grass
it's been a minute it's been a minute
yes we dropped off graphic we dropped
off the rings of power a little bit on
this show apologies to all our ROP fans
out there
we just had so much hassle to dragon
attack we just got a little uh we got it
sidetracked on it but I do want to wrap
up with a little just kind of overview
of talking Tolkien a little overview of
rings of power what did you think of the
show overall I really enjoy day I liked
it once it started getting fighty yeah
you like the battle when the battle
started kicking I like the battles but
to be fair before the battles started
kicking off there were just certain
groups I liked a lot more than others
because I liked uh the dwarfs and I
liked the guy that was friends with this
is why we didn't talk
I liked him I liked him I didn't really
which I horrible I guess for me to say I
didn't really care for the elves
yeah they honestly I'll be honest they
try they make it really hard to really
like these I'm kind of with the man the
the men and women of the world of Middle
Earth get out of here it was more to be
fair it was like yeah they were led by a
guy that kind of sucked oh he sucks he
sucks he sucks so that's why I was
genuinely like you guys are blindly
following someone that really sucks for
like thousands of years they gotta deal
with this and they have the deal for him
so it's like yeah it just seems like you
guys were sent to make the world a worse
place
and we focused on them so much so which
we had to because the two main
characters but it was still like our
three main characters so I was like but
I was like
um I don't like them I kind of get like
King Durham when he's like I don't care
about these out like these elves living
for thousands of years and now they're
worried that they're gonna die like yeah
the rest of us 40 years and then the
Rock Falls like get out of here
I will say the show was stunning
visuals just absolutely beautiful they
throw a lot of money into this show and
it showed I mean like some really
beautiful Vistas beautiful music
incredible costumes uh and it was like a
heavy fantasy show I one thing I love
about House of the Dragon is how it
tries to get into like the nitty-gritty
of like okay what is like the day-to-day
life like sometimes what's it like to
have children what's it like to pay
taxes what's it like to go to a Mummers
farce uh and you know Rigs of power is
doing a bigger job of doing a more Inc
all-encompassing fantasy story going
here going there going all over the
place telling these big Tales talking in
big grandiose terms having these
monologues and speeches uh it it is that
they're very different shows and I think
you both would be appreciated in their
own ways but it was an incredibly
beautiful show I'm interested to see
where it goes as someone who has not
read any of the Tolkien books I was
learning a lot on that show and it was
pretty fascinating uh I will ask you
this one question about uh rings of
power though Jessica if you had spend
all your time with one group we know
it's not going to be the elves who would
you pick to be like your one group of
people to like spend time with I don't
want it to be but it ended up it
probably would end up being the harfords
the hard foots the reason I say I don't
want it to be is because
other than the dwarves they work really
hard they work really hard to hide
themselves constantly moving the last
thing
and then you're like honestly the
weakest of like when I say the weakest I
mean like when they're like okay well we
have to leave him behind because we got
to go hide it's like you're gonna be
eaten by any creature that's there yeah
because you're a heart like you're just
that's why they hide that's why they're
gonna be so scared all the time and
they're always on their toes about
everything and I was like that would be
the life I would hate to have but
they're the greatest people I think
they're they I love the family I love
the community I love always being there
for each other in this like World of
like we give what we take and like we
also share what we find like so I was
like I love this I would want to well
and they these hard foots eventually
they do settle down and they realize we
gotta stop moving we gotta care we gotta
have a community we gotta build and they
become Hobbits and it's beautiful and
then I wouldn't want to be them during
the actual Rings yeah during the Lord of
the Rings not great not so much not
great for the habits um I think I would
picked the dwarves the dwarves are
pretty cool dude they're sick it's tough
you might die in a cave-in you spend a
lot of time Underground but they got
natural light coming in you spent a lot
of time Underground I like I already
spent my entire life in my room you got
some cool armor you get to grow a nice
beard good food not many wins a good
time
not many women but beautiful women yeah
oh when they show up I'm here for them
with beautiful songs how many women did
we see we saw a few female droids I mean
we mainly only seen Durham's wife yeah
for most of it but there were some
others hanging around in this I assume
they all can sing like her I think she's
like the best singer yeah
I don't mind that's still a compliment
that's still a really good that's a good
deal all the backup singers you see in
the world they're all amazing that is
though that is the hard part imagine
you're a little dwarf and you wanna you
wanna sing you want to sing you want to
be a singer everyone can hear you when
you're practicing
if you're bad at singing The Rocks might
collapse oh my God yeah oh my is that
just the Tomato never mind I can't be a
I can't do that because I'm always I
want to hang out those drawers we don't
want to hang out with the elves and keep
me out of numenor it's boring it's
beautiful I just don't like who's
leading it also leave before it's too
late that's all Lord of the Rings what
happens that's the problem that's the
problem I would have been at numenor and
I would have drowned Jessica's there at
the bar like screw these elves get them
out of here and I get my comeuppance
that's the hard part she's not telling
the people that like Hey we're about to
die
um I know if you're having this vision
of The Great Wave maybe one tell me so I
can leave if I need to some people just
choose to stay yeah we know how it works
some people are like hey I'm gonna stay
here because and I would be that person
being like where's my first ship out get
me out of here well Jessica what a
season it's been for uh for us this is
this is it for big question pretends
Talking Dragon dragons for now you'll be
putting talking dragons into deep
storage for a little bit until our
Disney shows return back into the Vault
until we get some more fantasy shows but
be sure to come back next week for the
return of the big question you all know
and love with a few little changes you
have to come check it out to see what
those are and one of the changes I won't
be there what you're not gonna do that I
I chose today to tell you that I'm not
doing it anymore I don't know if that's
true you have to tune in next week to
find out uh but don't forget to check
out our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmart.com follow Jessica at
Lulu Clemons follow me at grin and
Barrick and be sure to subscribe to big
question wherever you get your podcast
or watch it or listen to it or whatever
you do do that subscribe to all of new
Rockstar social channels we got great
stuff all over the place thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]